jean-michel je suis tombé sur une vidéo
tout à l'heure mais sa part juste suis
tombé sur un sondage puisque vous allez
avoir trente secondes jean-michel je
vous donnais un panier regardez regardez
la graisse est comme ça et vous
inquiétez pas on va vous la portez vous
allez voir vous avez tout compris de
quoi il s'agit il ya dans ces sacs
le panier moyen qu'il y a voilà pour
tous les produits du quotidien
d'accord d'accord je vous le dis dans le
sac qu'on a mis le contenu donc du
panier moyen de la française
responsables des achats
la fameuse ménagère d'après une enquête
ipsos quand vous allez l'avoir 30
secondes pour trouver tous les pions
tous les produits qu'il ya dans ce
fameux panier d'accord je prenais
connais le doublé on peut là on peut
l'installer géant messieurs merci assez
lourd bah oui n'aura bien sûr il ya tous
les produits mettez vous bien de face
mais qu'elle joue bien comme ça tenez
vous droit voilà tenez vous droit merci
vous de tout le tenait par les c la
hausse est de 50 kg est né comme ça et
on va lui mettre arrêtez-vous l'assiette
c'est nous en tout cas alors à 50 qu'ils
allaient là oui c'est pas vous inquiéter
pas alors que c'est très simple vous
inquiétez pas jean-mi attention 30
secondes pour savoir ce qu'il y à là
dedans c'est parti tout ce qui entre au
off soda jambon saucisses aubergines
tarama du lait du beurre les amphiboles
oeuf la sauce et son ouïe
ah oui aussi complexe sucre en poudre
poivre de confiture combattants
troisième café café on attendait que
j'ai testé il vous reste et les e jeudi
du zouk one ils étaient les deux les
[Rires]
regards des réponses et je suis bon
joueur j'ai perdu mes dates avaient
gagné
les récupérer les sacs
je vais récupérer les sacs parce que les
sacs ullevi rajoute à ça regardez dehors
ce qu'il y a c'est un cas nous qu'on a
rempli avec toute l'équipe de production
et sa part tout de suite aux restos du
on va rajouter bien sûr q séries et
c'est vrai que ce camion par tout de
suite aux restos du coeur il ya plein
plein plein de produits et c'est vrai
qu'en ce moment je vous lis avec ce qui
se passe il ya énormément de gens qui
vont vers les restes du coeur et les
restos du coeur ont besoin de nous donc
on les aidera pendant toute la période
vraiment et ils ont énormément besoin de
nous à merci et merci mesdames vous
embêtez pas si ça m'embête si j'aime
bien quand tes propres
j'aime bien quand il